[Musik]
mein name ist leopold druck ich bin 29
jahre alt und arzt an der charité
[Musik]
damit kann jeder merkel verbinde ich
eine politische konstante der letzten 60
jahre auf die man sich sachlich und
seriös verlassen konnte
meine erkrankung heißt hier ist rolf
stiska sie das ist eine angeborene sehr
seltene besondere kleinwuchs form bei
dieser kleinen wuchsform ist eben noch
die besonderheit das ist auch mit gelenk
kontrakt uhren einhergeht und daher kann
ich nicht so weit laufen ich kann
kleinen stück laufen aber bin primär im
rollstuhl unterwegs zusätzlich
[Musik]
er kann sehr schnell sein ich glaube ich
hätte den job
habe ich ja auch motorunterstützung
macht man gleich ein bisschen sport
natürlich ist es so dass ich vielleicht
nicht überall ran komme deswegen habe
ich zum beispiel zu dem fall paula mit
dabei das ist mein arbeits assistentin
da habe ich ganz viele unterschiedliche
studierende aus verschiedenen semestern
auch mehrere weil die natürlich nicht so
viel erhalten wollen wie ich jetzt die
begleiten mich dann eben den ganzen tag
oder auch tatsächlich auch in 24 stunden
mit leber arbeiten macht total spaß für
mich ist ganz cool weil ich mega den
guten einblick in der medizin und vor
allem wenn die anästhesie
für mich war schon immer relativ klar
dass ich arzt werden möchte meine eltern
sind beide ärzte und ärztinnen ich bin
sehr inclusive aufgewachsen tatsächlich
würde zum beispiel die grundschule dann
für mich nochmal barrierefrei umgebaut
als ich dann auf die grundschule thal
meine mutter und eben auch mein vater
haben wir sehr viel gekämpft und ich
dachte jede hürde die da kommt kann man
auch ohne probleme überwinden wenn man
es denn möchte
so
fängt das ist die schleuse
wir schauen uns natürlich sind euch
zufällt klar habe ich besonderheiten
durch den rollstuhl im alltag also jede
stufe ist für mich natürlich ein
hindernis deswegen ist es natürlich umso
schöner wenn möglichst viele
barrierefrei gestaltet
mit der frage wo der plan
war interessanterweise sein erster test
and damals natürlich hat man irgendwie
so seine vorbehalte und fragt sich ok
klappt das eigentlich so gut aber rio
hat das studium total gut gemeistert und
dann als er seine facharztausbildung
begonnen hat und es dann für ihn auch in
den op saal ging da war mir dann klar
okay jetzt schon so viele schritte
gemacht also lesen sie bei beispiel dass
inklusion einfach gut klappen kann und
welche größe was zutaten
krankenhaus ist sehr inklusiver ort muss
man sagen alles ist ebenerdig ist kein
stufen alle schilder elektrisch das
bedenkt man immer nicht aber sie sind
sehr in diesen arbeitsplatz wenn man
irgendwo
mir ist natürlich eine eine
bundesregierung wichtig die sich
inklusion auf die agenda schreibt mit
einer exklusiven gesellschaft wie ist
vielleicht auch manche er dann wollen
und eigentlich sollte es ja über thema
sein ist ja gar nicht nur menschen mit
behinderung sondern eben auch für für
menschen mit migrationshintergrund oder
eben das große ganze dahinter also das
ist ja das mit man inklusion auch ein
bisschen verstehen muss und wenn man das
kapiert hat und das als großes über
thema sieht dann kann man ja auch so
eine kultur dafür irgendwie schafft
hierfür ein schönes zusammenleben in
diesem land
so ich muss hier tatsächlich einmal
medikament geben weil ihr blut war
richtig schlecht ist
magst du dich einmal rechts von mir
hinstellen
nicht um sich an sorge um den blutdruck
also der ist jetzt nicht dramatisch
schief aber sie hat in relativ hohen
sieg kam und gleich nochmal 9 die fusion
kleben haben stecken damit sie auch
flüssigkeit bekommt auch das hilft den
blutdruck zu steigern tatsächlich und
genau das ist so gerade das was wir
machen
super tanken da um mich macht aus dass
ich versuche der inklusiv zu nehmen das
miteinander mir einfach sehr sehr
wichtig ist sowohl im beruflichen als
auch im privaten und
dass ich mir wünsche dass das eben auch
eine kultur des zusammenlebens für uns
alle ist haben sie vor irgendwas
geträumt
patienten und patientinnen begegnen mir
tatsächlich sehr aufgeschlossen ich
glaube das ist auch mit der wahrnehmung
des des berufs des arztes oder der
ärztin zusammenhängt das ist eben ein
sehr respektvolle umgang ist mit dieser
berufsgruppe
als immer gut geklappt also ich meine
ist gut wach geworden wir konnten die
gut ex probieren gleich rüber aufs bett
gehüpft lasst uns mal gucken wir weiter
machen können war der saal ist jetzt zu
ende
als ich nämlich nicht hätte man gerade
im rollstuhl wird fahrgäste teilweise
auch in merkels kabinett gewesen hätte
ich mal kurz mit der tür geholfen oder
so und in solchen momenten merkt man das
dann irgendwie wieder
[Musik]
paris zusammen mal ich bin am überlegen
doch mal einkaufen zu gehen
ohne das mittlerweile 13 jahren im kwg
unterschiedlichen leuten und ganz
unabhängig auch von meiner behinderung
wo es natürlich auch vorteile hat in der
wg zu wohnen dass er einem auch mal
jemand tatsächlich helfen kann bin ich
auch einfach so ein typ mensch der super
gerne mit mehreren leuten zusammen wohnt
um abends wenn man von der anstrengenden
arbeit kommt auch einfach noch mal
zusammen glas wein zu trinken ja ich
gehe jetzt einkaufen für die
wgk jetzt keine kiloweise wasserflaschen
klar auf jeden fall zum tauschen jetzt
auch den rollstuhl also ich einem
anderen rollstuhl mit zum einkaufen das
wäre mit dem hochfahren natürlich auch
nicht zum einkaufen ohne frage aber der
andere rolle hat vorteile kleiner ist
für mich bedeutet mobilität im alltag
teilzuhaben in all seinen facetten und
auch sie würden natürlich egal ist gegen
klar dass zu recht logisch
diese mobilität muss eben auf der einen
seite von meiner umgebung gewährleistet
werden damit ich mich auch möglichst
mobil in dieser umgebung bewegen kann
du hast natürlich recht wenn der boden
so ein arsch ist gerade bei uns jetzt in
einer alternden gesellschaft wenn man
sich das vorstellt ich jetzt mal mit
rollator unterwegs haben auch schon eine
hüpfburg das muss man ganz ehrlich sagen
das auch so standard fußwege natürlich
bei jedem frei sind und auch bei ihrem
freigehalten werden selbst wenn die
baustelle ist es muss ja was
die schule hier im bett wird zurück
eigentlich muss man ehrlich sagen viel
los immer viele leute unterwegs sieht
man ja auch ganz viele verschiedene
kulturen das echt cool wenn alle kunden
an das muss man auch irgendwie mal
positiv sehen und wenn man irgendwo eine
treppe hat da nicht hochkommen wir eine
stufe kann man auch leute wie der kran
auf
das sind eben auch abgesenkte bordsteine
und das ist leider auch in berlin nicht
überall gegeben aber das sind einfach so
kleinigkeiten so kleinigkeiten die
eigentlich standard sein müssen das
betrifft natürlich auch jeden anderen
menschen im rollstuhl oder mit einer
gehbehinderung oder auch muss man
natürlich auch sagen auch mit dass die
beeinträchtigungen da kann man stolpern
das sind halt sachen das sind
kleinigkeiten die halt auch trotzdem
sehr relevant sind für selbstbestimmte
leben
so können sie da einmal diesen großen
tomaten ja
danke
das ist natürlich jetzt zum punkt kommen
jetzt natürlich auch nicht überall wann
muss man ganz klar sagen
und unterbewusst entscheide ich mich
jetzt natürlich aktiv auch er für die
produkte die in meiner reichweite sind
das ist auch so da könnte natürlich auch
zum supermarkt sich auch überlegen aber
eher in der höhe stapelt anstatt die
vertical run zu listen
dafür wäre ich ziemlich cool das ist
jetzt halten gefrierfach was eben nicht
nur gefriertruhe ist wie der alte
gefriertruhe wir hier auch hier müsste
ich einen tauchen also hier komme ich im
leben nicht wahr ganz ehrlich und hier
ist es tatsächlich überhaupt kein ding
also hier kann ich einfach
oder mittel einfach
die gefriert öffnen und kommen so dem
sogar auch hier oben rand was ganz geil
ist tatsächlich und das wäre also das
ist halt nicht so eine kleinigkeit die
aber für die barrierefreiheit total
supermärkte in deutschland sind
grundsätzlich erst mal mehr oder weniger
barrierefrei aber es ist so dass solche
kleinigkeiten das bezahl terminals wo
man seine ec-karte vorhält oder sein
handy dass das eben auch nah dran ist
und nicht auf der anderen seite vom
fließband denn da komme ich ja aus
meiner mühe überhaupt berühre das heißt
es sind so kleinigkeiten hier aber
extrem wichtig sind wie bei junghans
[Applaus]
ja natürlich hat es werden in dem sinne
zu überwinden aber ich glaube jeder
mensch von uns auch hat irgendwas mit
sich also ein alter mensch der
vielleicht nicht mehr so weit laufen
kann oder schlecht sieht und am ende ist
es dann eben wichtig dass sowohl die
personen damit umgehen lernt und aber
auf der anderen seite eben auch vom
staat von der gesellschaft die
möglichkeiten bekommen trotzdem eine
aktive teilhabe am öffentlichen leben im
sinne der inklusion eben zu haben egal
in welchem alter egal in welchen bereich
sozial
[Musik]
das machen wir heute
ich betreibe seit ich zwölf bin
sportschießen luftgewehr und
kleinkaliber habe dann klassische
karriere hingelegt so zu sagen dass ich
irgendwann landesmeister wurde
irgendwann zum ersten mal zur deutschen
meisterschaft gefahren bin noch in
jungen jahren dann vom nachwuchs trainer
der nationalmannschaft entdeckt wurde
und dann auch tatsächlich von 2010 bis
12 und 13 die nationalmannschaft war
und quasi mit als highlight auch bei den
paralympics in london 2012 hat auch
nicht mehr so richtig rein ehrlich
arbeiten
wachstums gewehr schon raus und auf den
tisch legen dann kommt es gleich zu
sagen was es ist sehr sehr inklusiver
sport würde ich sagen sportschießen
bringt sehr sehr viele verschiedene
menschen zusammen und lässt sich eben
auch und das finde ich auch sehr wichtig
auch gerade auch von menschen mit
schweren behinderungen
ausführen weil es ihm hilfsmittel gibt
um jemanden dann zu unterstützen und das
macht diesen sport extrem spannend und
vielseitig
[Musik]
ich habe sehr viel als trainer von ihm
profitiert ganz ehrlich ich habe früher
nie wirklich über inklusion nachgedacht
noch ziemlich diese menschen
kennengelernt habe finde ich es extrem
wichtig dass man halt nicht mehr
unterscheidet weil ich finde es gibt da
nichts zu unterscheiden weil die
menschen haben alle frauen nach
teilungen muss sie nun wirklich
kennenlernen wollen auf einer ebene
miteinander zu kommunizieren und das ist
das wichtige und das ist im moment noch
meine behinderung bringt mich schon in
gewissen situationen dazu sehr ehrgeizig
zu sein um eben auch mir selber zu
zeigen dass ich das kann dass ich das
hinkriege das ist für mich kein problem
darstellt zu sein und auch überhaupt
kein thema ist auch eine doktorarbeit zu
schreiben natürlich
ganz klar dass mir gerade nicht zu
anstrengend ja ich glaube ich kann auch
die fahrrad fahren verlernt man auch
nicht
hat mir spaß gemacht hat ich war gerne
mal wieder ein paar schüsse zu machen
auch jetzt nach der langen pause
wer jetzt ganz schön fertig muss ich
sagen und auch schon nach irgendwie
knappen 30 schuss aber ich hab schon
bald nochmal anzugreifen über die noch
mal deutscher meister zu werden oder so
mal gucken was so geht
[Musik]
ich könnte überall mit dem auto
empfangen aber bewusst fahre ich auch
viel bahn auch viel auf weite strecken
mit der bahn und liegt einmal daran dass
ich eben nicht aufgrund meiner
behinderung nicht einschränken möchte
und dann möchte ich eben auch
tatsächlich was für eine energiewende
tosen für den klimaschutz
also auf situationen gab wurde auf zu
kaputt war definitiv dann werden die
optionen langsam raane also dann ist im
zweifel das taxi was versteht die option
das kostet wieder geld also das ist
schon so eine sache
man hat in den zehn jahren die ich jetzt
hier in berlin lebe alleine hat sich das
total viel getragen nicht nur mit
fahrstühlen sondern auch eben das ist
verläuft wieder flur barren gibt also
ohne schwelle das ist aber eben auch
noch nicht optimal und selbst die
neuesten die cs die jetzt seit einem
jahr draußen sind haben drei stufen und
sind keine niederflur ics was ich
erstaunlich finde ich muss da vielleicht
ganz nach vorne zum fahrer denn s reifen
etwas für die bahn kommt es gibt welche
meiner hohen stufen ruhig tatsächlich
nicht alleine und kommen
[Musik]
selbst bestimmt das leben bedeutet eben
auch dass ich eigentlich alleine liebe
ankommen kann und zwar an jeder stelle
wo ich will und nicht ganz bis nach
vorne danke
erst mich je nach tagesform da jeder
mensch ist mal um die besser und
schlechter gelaunt nervt ich mich schon
dass ich es brauche aber ich kann damit
glaube ich ganz gut umgehen der fahrer
weiß jetzt dass ich hier schon braucht
weil ich immer leicht und gesagt hat
also der weiß bis zur bergstation ich
haben will hat er sich hoffentlich
gemerkt und wenn ja dann steht dann
vielleicht mit erwärmt haben
danke schön
danke
[Musik]
am ende muss man oder wir auch als
gesellschaftlich in behinderung leisten
können auch mental leisten können ich
glaube da ist es auch wirklich die
pflicht des sozialstaates und das glaube
ich vom tiefsten herzen eben dafür zu
sorgen dass jeder die möglichkeiten
bekommt eben so zu nehmen wie er möchte
und da eben auch noch einmal mehr tut
für die inklusion für alle menschen in
deutschland
[Musik]
wir wollen noch mehr porträts sehen dann
schaut in der mediathek vorbei
[Musik]